[Musik]
anna fühlt sich das gut an
heute reden wir über die schönste sache
der welt geld die geilste lobbyarbeit
ist die die sich direkt mit geld
beschäftigt
ihr wisst ja man muss geld ausgeben
[Musik]
um geld zu verdienen deutschland ist
eine der wunderbarsten bananenrepubliken
der welt es gibt kein verbindliches
lobby-register die unterlagen zur
parteienfinanzierung wird immer noch
nicht offen dargelegt dass sollten ganz
normale leute also leute wie ihr sehen
können welcher partei ich geldgeber
moment kompromissvorschlag wir
veröffentlichen stattdessen die
speisekarte der bundestags kantine
mittwoch holzplastik mit bratkartoffeln
96 salatteller peter altmaier mit vier
ganzen schinken 850 deutschland belegt
im ranking der größten steueroasen den
siebten platz
das einzige eu-land das noch schlechter
bewertet wird als wir ist luxemburg wir
sind fast so asozial luxemburg
durchschnitt durchschnitt anstatt das
steuerhinterziehungs weltmeister ja
jetzt freu dich doch mal war ich hab'
ich hatte ja gerne was geben aber mein
geld nicht leider auf den bahamas
was hier alles möglich ist wenn man geld
hat wer erinnert sich noch an den comic
skandal
und das liegt so ich verkaufen aktien an
einen harmlosen kleinanleger hier
dargestellt durch einen x-beliebigen
hannoveraner der kauft aktien aber über
einen dritten typen hier dargestellt
durch al capone wenn jetzt die dividende
ausgeschüttet wird zahle ich
kapitalertragssteuer gleichzeitig haben
wir die aktien so schnell hin und her
dass keiner mehr weiß leben sie
eigentlich gehört und dann erstattet der
staat die steuer zurück und zwar sowohl
wir als auch carsten maschmeyer
dem fiktiven man wie beim hütchenspiel
und bezahlen darf den ganzen bums die
allgemeinheit hier mal dargestellt durch
diese familie von absoluten volltreffer
als ob man einem junk erlaubt sich
selber rezepte auszustellen 32
milliarden euro wurden dem deutschen
staat so geklaut und wenn ihr euch fragt
wie zum henker kann das egal sein
lobbyismus bellver wir haben die gesetze
mitgeschrieben
der bankenverband hatte ein maulwurf
direkt im finanzministerium
20 jahre hat es gedauert bis man comics
geschäfte so verboten hat warte mal da
fällt man bezahlen
[Musik]
so leute das hier wies brezelbacken was
sagt ein milliardär zum finanzminister
der vor einem riesenhaufen steuergeld
steht und wer in deutschland einmal
reich ist da bleibt es auch zusammen mit
der politik verändern wie lobbyisten all
die schlimmen dinge die es früher einmal
gab wie die vermögenssteuer oder die
höhere erbschaftssteuer auf
firmenvermögen steuern schon bei dem
wort kriegt man rennpferd ausschlag
wer ein herz für reiche leute hat der
kann es weit bringen bis zum
finanzminister passt auf dass keine
finanztransaktionssteuer einführt
kapiert nur weil in der spd heißt das
noch lange nicht dass sie machen ganz
was du willst
[Musik]